this video sponsored by blue apron the
first hundred wisecrack fans to sign up
for blue apron at the link in the
description will get $50 off the first
two weeks stick around for some tacos
hey wisecrack jared again for a
franchise so surrounded in mystery it
seems fitting that nobody had a clue the
Cloverfield paradox had even been made
let alone that it was being released
with an hours of its announcement during
the Superbowl now there are plenty of
reasons why the Cloverfield paradox
should have worked and plenty of reasons
why it didn't but we're gonna focus on
the element that makes two largely
unrelated scripts so unique and cohesive
and makes the third one such an epic
fail that element our relationship to
reality and trauma welcome this
wisecrack addition on the Cloverfield
paradox what went wrong and spoilers
ahead for all the Cloverfield movies
before we dip into that secret sauce a
recap of the Cloverfield paradox is in
order
the year is 2028 and the world is in the
midst of an energy crisis
the crew aboard Cloverfield Station are
orbiting earth to test the experimental
shepherd particle accelerator which they
hope will save the world by producing
safe clean energy just before they turn
on the machine though we overhear an
interview with a writer who thinks that
turning on the particle accelerator will
open a wormhole to other dimensions and
release god-knows-what onto an
unsuspecting population and surprise
this is exactly what happens
they are teleported into another
dimension across space where they
experience the combined horrors of
phantom limbs creepy crawlers and faulty
wiring the crew must figure out how to
get home and well you can probably
figure out where it goes from there if
there's one thing we should be excited
about getting into the Cloverfield
paradox it's answers what was the giant
monster that attacked New York at the
end of the first one did it survive the
nuke if we hope to get those answers in
10 Cloverfield Lane well we're out of
luck instead we get Walter Sobchak
reminding us that this isn't Nam there
are rules yeah great - what summits
turned as our protagonist escapes his
clutches she enters a world of pain and
aliens
but the Cloverfield paradox does give us
answers those giant monsters it's from
another dimension
the camcorder video it might not even be
from the same timeline so why isn't
getting these answers more rewarding
Cloverfield and 10 Cloverfield Lane are
both films about trauma both the trauma
one might associate with war natural
disaster or extra dimensional aliens
destroying your home and the trauma of
being physically trapped in a
relationship with a person that's gonna
go full Jack Torrance at any minute 10
Cloverfield Lane brings up all the same
aspects of abusive relationships
possible gaslighting there's nowhere to
go Michelle and threats of violence
interspersed with normal family fun but
the first two movies aren't just about
dealing with trauma they're about the
impossibility of fully comprehending
that trauma these insanely violent
encounters with a lack of closure speak
to one of the fundamental difficulties
of navigating the world for philosopher
and sometimes kleptomaniac jacques lacan
there exists a fundamental human
inability to fully grasp what he calls
the real or the world as it truly is
Cloverfield throws us in the midst of an
alien invasion that evades easy
description
we're often given the byproduct of
what's happening or people's reactions
but almost never get the source of the
turmoil in an explainable way like when
the head of the Statue of Liberty comes
rolling down the street or a horrific ly
disfigured woman is begging for help in
the first Cloverfield the reality of
what's happening only sparsely comes in
news segments in the background one of
the ways Cloverfield achieves this is
with perspective it's filmed POV style
shot by the characters in the movie and
begins with a detailed look at our main
cast of characters during a party for
the protagonist Rob in the middle of the
shindig they're interrupted by an
explosion signaling the monster invasion
their battle for survival it's intercut
with older video that is being recorded
over which gives you glimpses into the
relationship between Rob and Beth this
subjective point of view means we only
ever get hints of where and what the
monster is how the military are
responding to it and even what it looks
like you know just like you would in
real life by shooting it this way we
don't know what kind of monster they are
facing but we do know who the characters
are and what they're facing personally
10 Cloverfield Lane employs a similar
technique it doesn't use this same POV
style to cut us off from the reality of
what's happening but rather uses a
concrete bunker to similar ends the
protagonist Michelle wakes up in a
bunker that she can't leave for reasons
that seemed suspicious to say the least
she's told she was rescued giving us how
I saved your life I think that's
acceptable and at the outside world is
deadly now if we suspect that Howard is
preparing to wear Michelle's skin we get
just enough interaction from the outside
world to give credence to his story but
not enough to truly know what's
happening as the movie ends we get
enough information to let us know that
things aren't going great for Earth but
not much else the control of information
in both movies is what makes them so
tense and entertaining we have to fill
in the gaps which instead of being
frustrating makes with a sort of thing
that spawns endless fan theories for
lacan that reality which seems to evade
us the real is disconnected from our own
personal experience only through
language or what he calls the symbolic
can we bridge the gap between our minds
and the reality beyond them what
Cloverfield explores is the chasm
between the real and language the
inability to bridge that gap the
characters and us the audience want
answers we want to understand what is
happening but the film withholds the
language to explain it that chasm for
Lacan is called lack and it's what
drives the tension of the first two
movies we all know what it's like to be
at a loss for words during a terrible
event footage of 9/11 shows onlookers
covering their mouths in silent horror
while watching the tragic events happen
in front of them it's no secret that the
cinema verite found footage style of the
original Cloverfield
was inspired by the events and coverage
of 9/11 that kind of cultural trauma
runs deep and was still a raw nerve at
the time of the trailers release mass
entertainment wasn't willing to return
to these sorts of disaster movies right
away but the movie is able to tap into
that post 9/11 anxiety by borrowing from
the structure of kaiju movies thereby
using a symbol to represent that shared
this is what makes it so cathartic 10
Cloverfield Lane released some eight
years later at a time of cultural
uncertainty and change was a paranoid
thriller that makes you question the
people around you against this gap
between language and reality the
Cloverfield paradox gives us its
antithesis science this is the paradox
excuse me particles interacting with
each other across two dimensions two
distinct realities in a multiverse while
there are certainly unexplained events
like why the hell did Monday's arm keep
moving after it was detached the whole
premise of the movie transdimensional
travel explains the origin of the
Cloverfield event in the first 15
minutes of the movie monsters demons
these to clarify you believe their
efforts to solve the energy crisis might
unleash demons not just here in the past
in the future and sure we're not saying
mysteries can't be solved or that
science can't do it but it shouldn't be
as background noise in the first half of
the movie turns out the terrifying and
Nebel monstrosity z' that have invaded
earth for reasons beyond our imagining
happened because science little
disappointing isn't it and if you're
gonna give an explanation or revelation
there's a certain way to do it
good examples tend to give us a paradigm
shift or clarify motives in exceptional
cases they can give you an entirely new
way to view the events prior like when
we find out the truth about Tyler Durden
or the man in black how does quantum
entanglement add to or reframe the
original Cloverfield stories it doesn't
and besides breaking away from the kind
of trauma that defined the first two
movies there is no central fear or
shared trauma for the audience to latch
onto
if Cloverfield was the fear of an
invasion and 10 Cloverfield Lane was the
fear of other people what's the central
fear of this movie fear of particle
accelerators peak oil by explaining away
the mystery almost as an afterthought
you Rob the audience not just of their
mystery but their catharsis while yes
explaining a mystery ruins the fun is
kind of an obvious point it's what
creates our desires for mystery that is
important to the Cloverfield movies
lakhan's idea of lack gets to the heart
of understanding why we love a good
mystery
and why JJ Abrams property seemed to
have such a hard time with resolving
those mysteries we're looking at you
lost those are the reality around us
always evades easy answers and the
language to describe it
we don't want everything explained not
just because we all like a good
conspiracy theory but because of the
catharsis that comes with the shared
experience of realizing that some things
can't
and sometimes shouldn't be put into
words the first two Cloverfield movies
knew this and played on that which is
what made them so interesting and
ultimately rewarding the Cloverfield
paradox paradoxically ruins the fun by
giving us all the answers and pretty
half-baked ones at that so what do you
think wisecrack can the movie have more
tastefully explained the mystery let us
know what you think in the comments and
as always thanks for watching
Hayes Cloverfield may not have been the
sci-fi Mindbender we'd hoped for but as
I found everything is made better with
tacos and in this case spicy black bean
and caramelized onion tacos from blue
apron blue apron unleashes your inner
Gordon Ramsay by sending farm-fresh
ingredients along with an easy-to-follow
recipe right to your door you never have
to leave the house again
finally in fact the first hundred
wisecrack fans to sign up with blue
apron via the link below will get 50
bucks off your first two weeks each meal
takes 40 minutes or less to cook all
under 800 calories per person and with a
large selection of menus updated weekly
there's something for the carnivores
vegetarians and really picky teens of
the family you know what I'm talking
about teens if you're looking for
something extra flavorful then I'd
recommend their Mediterranean menu
featuring dishes like oregano chicken
and Calabrian chili shrimp it's perfect
for all the lovers of olive oil and
Spain click below again to get this
awesome deal and I'm off to eat a family
sized portion by myself peace guys
[Applause]